sorry thank you so much glamour oh
you're there J I was looking to where
you're going to be the whole time and
thank you Joe this means so much to me
and you have just been so immensely
supportive of me and the whole YouTube
and blogging world which has been
amazing the last few years have just
been I'm going to put this award down
can I put it here okay story is heavy um
so yeah the last few years have just
been crazy
I've been making my youtube videos for
almost seven years about beauty fashion
and baking and I never thought I would
be where I am today and have millions of
people watching my videos I want to say
an enormous thank you to the people who
do watch my videos and they are so
amazing and I also want to thank my team
who are all here and Lucy Georgia Kate
and Dom Dom's not here sadly but um to
the girls thank you so much you guys
work tirelessly and put up with me and
my crazy ideas and when I want to just
have everything done in one day and get
to excited about everything and thank
you Jim for always being there for me
and you're just the best and thank you
to my family for being my biggest
supporters um sorry this is like a
really scary um so uh YouTube has been
um sorry guys I'm going to show you come
to cuddle you won't show me by one of
them and I want to make sure I say what
I have to say so um YouTube has been
such an incredible platform for me
without I wouldn't have been able to do
my makeup line on my book it's also
given me the opportunity to become an
ambassador for the global goals and I
feel so privileged to be involved with
them and the amazing work that they do I
just want to let all girls and women
know out there that um I'm not the
typical typical girl that everything
goes right for and or you know had a
massive lucky break or anything I'm just
a big dreamer and always have been since
I was
child and I just want everyone to know
that if you dream big and work hard
anything can happen so I am I feel
really honored to be the first person to
receive this new award and thank you Joe
it's amazing to have my peers and I be
recognized for everything that we do and
this is an really special so thank you